un mot encore sur cette campagne
électorale qui a déjà vu son lot de
démission de candidats qui sont
retrouvés dans l'embarras à cause de
certains propos controversés qu'ils ont
tenus sur les réseaux sociaux
faudrait qu'en fait on a l'impression
qu'ils sont de plus en plus nombreux et
ça remonte parfois à très loin
oui on peut en parler par exemple à la
candidate libérale dans calgary madame
alaa bougera pas en fait c'est une femme
qui est toute jeune elle a 21 ans milla
qui remontaient dans son passé dans son
compte twitter il ya quatre ans elle
avait 17 ans elle avait eu des propos
assez virulent avec un pro israélien
elle a dû démissionner quelques heures
après même chose également pour madame
joy davis c'est en colombie-britannique
toujours une candidate libérale elle
l'avait mentionné sur son facebook fumer
de la marijuana pendant qu'on est
enceinte et bien ça va améliorer
l'intelligence de l'enfant évidemment ça
n'a pas tenu couac chez les libéraux les
démocrates ne sont pas en reste non plus
avec morgan wilden ça c'est en nouvelle
écosse lui en fait il avait également eu
des propos assez virulents contre israël
il a démissionné également à catherine
swampy en alberta et néo-démocrates qui
en 2011 avait eu un échange assez
violent plein de grossièretés avec un
des internautes est là finalement elle a
eu l'absolution du parti puisqu'il est
toujours candidate dans sa
circonscription
du côté du bloc elle a fait les frais
dans les premiers jours de campagne de
on a épluché civile tout ce qui avait
été dit sur elle et notamment sur un des
médias sociaux elle avait mentionné à la
réponse à la question qu'est-ce que vous
emmèneriez en cas de guerre nucléaire en
trois objets à la vie dit et je cite mon
cell un pénis et d'un dea de chips alors
bon elle est toujours candidate pour
l'instant ce qui n'est pas le cas de son
collègue jacques tremblay dans mon kahn
qui a démissionné après avoir enfoncé
sur sa page facebook
le front national de jean-marie le pen
et puis enfin un autre exemple du côté
des conservateurs maintenant il faut
dire qu'il y en a beaucoup des exemples
on en a pris juste 2 par partie parce
que pour être assez un parent c'est ben
ali qui te colle lui a démissionné parce
qu'il avait posté sur sa page facebook
des vidéos du npd ça fait un peu
désordre quand on est conservateur et
puis enfin un people can qui lui avait
réduite et des images notamment une d'un
photomontage de migrants disant qu'ils
l'avaient été combattre aux côtés de
l'état islamique s'était pas vraiment
mais il existe quand même
moyen de vers les partis font des
vérifications sont des candidats mais
c'est difficile avec les réseaux sociaux
ben c'est difficile parce qu'il ya trois
cent trente huit circonscriptions au
canada donc ça fait énormément de
candidats qu'il faut passer en revue les
partis disent qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens et pas le temps de le faire et
puis surtout une multiplication
évidemment des réseaux sociaux vous
reconnaissez ici peut-être quelques
icônes il n'a bien plus que ça alors
imaginez le travail de vérification
il reste encore une vingtaine jours donc
d'autres controverses en perspective
mais probablement il parce que
curieusement le paradoxe dans tout ça
c'est que les partis n'ont pas le temps
de vérifier leurs propres candidats mais
ils ont tant de le faire pour les
adversaires alors ils attendent la date
butoir du 28 donc lundi prochain où on
ne peut plus changer la liste de
candidats pour peut-être sortir d'autres
choses et torpillé certaines campagnes
parce qu'après on peut plus mais
d'autres candidats pour les remplacer
donc ça joue dur quand même une époque
totalement merci